foreign
hi Dr John thanks for taking my call of
course what's happening
um okay so I I wrote down a couple
thoughts and then I'll follow up with my
question if that's okay very cool
absolutely
okay so my call today is regarding my um
little sister-in-law we love her very
very much but I recently found out that
she's been dabbling in cocaine
um and obviously this is very concerning
to us but equally concerning is a
pattern of behavior that we've witnessed
over the past few years with her
um she's only 21 but since she was
around 16 we've seen a lot of deception
in all of her relationships not just
with the family
um and on the outside right now it seems
like she's doing okay she's got a good
job working in finance she's got her own
place she's got a boyfriend
um she's pretty responsible
um but then we learn about things that
she's lying to us or lying to others
about and um I guess a terrifying thing
to us is that the lies seem to get
bigger and um nothing is really slowing
her down and sadly I'm afraid that if we
talk to her about
you know the cocaine usage that she'll
just lie and deny that she's doing it
sure
um so my question is do we still try to
talk to her and if so what can we say
this one's hard
and unfortunately because of my previous
career I'm just man I had this
conversation a lot it's hard
yeah
um
how did you guys find out she's doing
coke
um
co-worker who is also a friend of
God Jim what happened when she was 16
was there stuff that went on in the
family did she have some abuse did she
get was have a boyfriend that got sight
like what what happened there
so she comes from a very loving home
um
she's one of five kids and she's the
youngest of five kids and um
um she got wrapped up with a boyfriend
when she was 16 and that's I think when
we started noticing some of the
destruction she had two phones one that
she would use to communicate with him
and he was
um much older than her I'd say he sounds
like he's older yeah yeah
and that's kind of how it all started
and then eventually
kind of surprised everybody surprised
and not surprised we kind of knew it was
coming but how old was this guy
um he was like 22. yeah so I want to
contextualize this for everybody okay so
when it comes to
actually let me let me back up a little
bit okay
um
i s i because of my experience working
with young people and because of people
that I'm in relationship with that I
love that I would consider close to me
I do not screw around with
cooking
okay it's it's um
that said I've I know multiple people
who say they only do it a couple times a
year like just Recreation
um and so I can't deny that I can't I
can't pretend that's not true that's
what they say
I can't and I know that we're we're the
country's being ravaged by an opioid
epidemic
but I've seen cocaine and its younger
cheaper sister math I've seen it just
destroy
right they just rages fire now here's
the catch what I learned over the years
was instead of
asking somebody why in the world are you
using cocaine
why in the world are you drinking the
cover up why in the world are you Phil
partying why in the world are you
whatever
I quit asking that question
and I started asking the question
what happened in your life
that made being you so painful that you
had to really go after some heavy stuff
to cover it up
yeah and
she could have had a very loving home
but she was raped and sexually abused
from the time she was 16 to 18 years old
by a 22 year old man
yeah
and so you see what I'm saying
yes and I would definitely agree with
you except
um I don't I mean it was rape of course
but she was very much a participant in
all of that at the same time oh Lacey I
I mean I I definitely am not like
absolutely but I'm standing up for her
but yes she was a kid and so I would
challenge the notion with all of my
heart that she's got a quote unquote
really loving family because a really
loving family would have gone to war to
keep their daughter from being raped
does that make sense
yup yup police were involved okay
okay and um it was her choice she did
she did not want any she wanted to just
brush it under the rug
and um
so I mean that's I guess and he had a
there was like a restraining order put
out against him but
um and then she wanted to just move on
with her life so that's I think what
everybody just did because
well and if
foreign
there can't be any lingering thought in
your mind in your husband's mind in the
family's mind that well she was asking
for it and she really wanted to go no we
don't think that that's what you said
yeah
like she was all in you know what I mean
yeah I mean we've this was over a couple
years and when we found out she was 18
mean and at that time she was like I'm
moving out I'm making my own decisions
what's in the passes in the past you
know so
I mean and she was like this is this is
my the love of my life you know
so that's what I say when when she was
all in
um you know
so
I think the
but I mean since then like they've split
up she's been with other men course yeah
I mean and I just feel like nothing
I I don't know what to tell her what to
say that we can try to just
and even when we try to have
relationships I mean we see her all the
time she's over her family dinners you
know she loves coming around but I just
feel like it's very surface-b because
even when we just ask her simple things
like oh what'd you do this weekend it's
a lie I mean there's I ca I feel like we
can't have connection with her because
just even the little things are just we
find out later oh that wasn't really
entirely true and and
something in her body
says that none of y'all are safe
none of y'all are trustworthy
none of you will still love me if you
really knew
yeah
and so I've got to escape with drugs
I've got to keep everybody in the arm's
length with dishonesty even as Wild As
It Gets
because from 16 to 18 these two people
who said they love me love me love me
love me had no idea that I was being
abused
nobody came and got me
and that sounds unfair and it sounds how
are we supposed to know we had five
other kids and blah blah blah
nobody came and got her
and she's gonna be chasing somebody tell
me that I'm worth being loved
that I've got value because the two
people are supposed to come rescue me
didn't show up yeah and it's easy to be
like well she keeps hooking up with
so-and-so and she keeps ended up with
another man another man her body is
Desperately Seeking somebody to say I
see all of you and I love you
yeah
and
um
the sucky thing about cocaine is it
works
it makes you
it lights up your brain like a like a
Christmas tree
and you can work better and faster than
people and it works until it kills you
yeah right and so
you are right on if you sit down and try
to have some Kumbaya conversation it's
not going to go very well or some sort
of after school special conversation
yeah it's not going to go well
um
the conversation to be had is a private
conversation probably with her brother
probably with Mom and Dad maybe with you
and somebody say
I'm so so sorry
and
I love you and I love you and I love you
and you're always welcome here
more and more information is not going
to solve this problem it's not a data
issue it's a connectivity issue
and she is a young
Beautiful Soul desperately searching for
somebody to say you're enough
yeah
is this bringing true
no it's hard
when we all find out found out because
at the time it was just a whirlwind of
what like we're just finding this out
she's moving out you know we're finding
the second phone we're finding all these
things
um and at the time she didn't want to
hear any of that you know she was just
like I'm on to my new man you know I
found this guy and I don't know well
that's what a great would have had the
opportunity what a great rapist and a
great child molester will do
is
make a child feel like they can't
breathe without them
yeah and
they get so intertwined with shame and
purpose
and worth
and somebody exciting and new and sexy
and with their own jaw jaw and car
whatever
becomes so magnetic
that just going home and sitting down
for dinner with the family
you know I mean like it so it it's like
me getting mad at my daughter when I
leave jelly beans everywhere she's seven
like that's on me
right you know what I mean I expect her
to want to eat jelly beans until she
can't fit another jelly bean inside of
her tiny little body
I expect that
it's up to me to say hey this isn't safe
this isn't healthy this is gonna make
you sick that's my job I'm dead
and so yes it's easy when you find an 18
year old or a 19 year old
to say oh my gosh you didn't follow our
family Rules you deceived us you lied to
us you had another phone you've been
sneaking out for years
I totally get that
yeah
and that's the
that response
is catastrophic
the response should be
God help us we missed it and I'm so
sorry we should have been there for you
we weren't
understand that you got a second phone
that you did this and that you can tell
everybody in the world as a 16 year old
you wanted this and you want to do this
and blah I don't you don't get that vote
when you're 16 because you're a child we
missed it and I'm sorry
you're please come home
yep does that make sense
so the whole family is gonna have to be
in on
that's not true that's not true because
there's going to be parents who cannot
they cannot take ownership in these kind
of moments they just can't
I've seen it too I've seen it my whole
career parents who just can't
internalize that they have any role to
play in something like this
and brothers and sisters who say hey man
she made her choices
and
people who look at her and say dude she
was oh she was a flirt she was always
dressing this way and say stupid hateful
hard things like that
and the reality is I always want to go
back to that 16 year old girl
they needed somebody to step in and they
didn't so
at some point someone's got to step in
now
and that might be you that might be you
that might be you looking at her and
saying listen to me very carefully
I know
that your parents should have stood us
like stepped in and they didn't we all
should have stepped in yeah and we
didn't and I'm sorry that was wrong
yeah and I love you
yeah no I can definitely say that
um maybe big brother too
yeah yeah
I felt I feel like I don't want to paint
them in a bad light because they
definitely were I mean it was a mix 50
50 of
um oh my gosh what's going on and we
love you please don't do this you know
what I mean so I definitely don't think
that that conversation wasn't it was had
but at that point I think she was
already kind of too far gone at that
point to listen but I'm hoping maybe now
um now that he's out of the picture and
you know
some years of that
maybe instead of sit down and have that
conversation maybe instead of her of
looking at her like she's too far gone
maybe looking at her like oh her body
got the message loud and clear no one
was going to pay attention
yeah
and so she went with the person that
paid attention
yeah
yeah no I mean I didn't mean like too
far gone like she's you know like I'm
superior or any any of that I just meant
she she was very invested into that
relationship absolutely and I wouldn't
think anything less I wouldn't think
anything less I'm imagining myself as a
16 year old and if some beautiful 22
year old woman had come and started
showing interest in me and telling me
that I was wonderful
right
I mean it would be ludicrous for me not
to be
like swooned by that
yeah so we have laws and people and
adults and all that stuff and so I I
can't I can't overstate
how big of a miss this was
and I can't overstate
that not using the words sexual assault
and rape
not using those words
is a disservice to what happened
and I can't overestimate how this her
healing will not happen outside of
relationship and at some point she's
going to find him
foreign
My Hope Is that they come from a place
that they are with people who love her
and have her best interests
and not who are just interested in
making sure the family looks good
and not keeping up the big loving and
we're all everything's wonderful and all
that kind of stuff
I hope it's from people who
take a knee and say
we missed it in our own house and I'm
sorry
foreign
[Music]